i'm here at the gigafactory grand
opening in austin texas
one of the big surreal things is that
before i ever met elon musk
before i ever did a podcast and did
videos and stuff like that
i actually went out to the grand opening
of the first gigafactory out in reno
nevada
and
to give a talk
and that was uh
that was a surreal experience
first of all to see american
manufacturer at scale
and second that also was a party
and it was like late into the night
and the thing i remember the most is
that like
3 or 4 a.m
whenever the party was wrapping up there
were still people that work for tesla
and
there's just this passion in their eyes
for what they're doing out there in the
desert
it's like in the middle it felt like in
the middle of nowhere in reno
and they uh
there was still this love for what they
were doing
and that that stayed with me because
that's the best of humanity to be a part
of something big like that
if you look at the scale of this thing
[Music]
i mean is there anything sexier
than the factory
that builds cars
in america
so of course like the idea
i think is beautiful the idea of
automation
when you build a prototype that first
prototype where you get to capture the
magic of the idea that's beautiful
but the most beautiful thing to me is
when you get to manufacture that idea at
scale
and you know even at that time to
imagine that
just a few years later you would get
hundreds of thousands of cars
manufactured and delivered a year i
think it's closing out on a million
tesla vehicles
to me as an ai person as a
that's the talk actually that i gave was
on semi autonomous vehicles out in reno
it's just amazing it's amazing that
there's been so many people that it that
it's possible to
to build an american car company that
does
something what autopilot is doing
it's just incredible of course there's
waymo
what cruz is doing it's also incredible
but to actually put
hundreds of thousands of vehicles that
are
doing what autopilot is doing
in the hands of real people especially
full self-driving fsd beta it's just
incredible all the surreal to me
personally just as one little amp
on this on this planet it's just
inspiring that people can dream
to do the impossible and make that
impossible a reality
for that to be here
in austin texas and for me to be here
just it's surreal just to look back
at that time in reno
uh
that i would get a chance to meet some
of these amazing people
and to sort of
get to witness some of these amazing
things
it's a dream come true
all right now let's go party
you